I'd like to welcome everyone to this
morning to gales and 4th annual day of
data we're very happy to have everyone
here my name is Jill parsec i'm the
associate university librarian for
science social science and medicine and
i'll be your host for the morning before
we do anything I want to just give a few
little logistics there will be photos
and video being taken throughout today
so that you're aware of that and give a
little courtesy to be photographers well
things are going on we ask you to
silence your cell phones I know
everybody is very important has a
million things going on but we tend turn
off the ringers coffee you've already
seen I hope downstairs lunch will be in
the same location this afternoon and
we'll have some instructions for you at
that point about how to line up queue up
to get down to lunch so that we don't
have a mob team restrooms there are two
restrooms right down the quarter right
near where you came in and then there
are a few more downstairs if you just go
down the stairs and down the hallway and
down another set of stairs the schedule
for thursday is on the web but we also
had some we handed out at the table as
you came in so if you need a schedule
you can pick one up there first thing
I'd like to say is thank you to all the
sponsors for the day of data first off
the office of the provost who has been
generous and very supportive in hosting
this the center for science and social
science information many staff members
who helped to make today happen the
Center for teaching and learning who is
supporting our video set up for the day
the digital humanities lab who also
heavily participated in the planning the
institution for social on policy studies
who's been a great supporter of day of
data from the beginning and did a lot of
the planning also the yellow institution
for network science also be contributors
to this event and sigma11 distinguished
visitor fund is also a supportive so
we're very grateful for our sponsors a
big thank you also to the Planning
Committee for the day of data which has
been superbly led by Michelle
Hudson Michelle actually deserves a hand
of applause other members of that
committee have been Kaylee Bohemia
Cassie duros I'm Erin Waka with Melanie
maxon tembo flowers Paul de Bello we
couldn't have done it without Paul Kate
ngayon Peter peduzzi l'amour pier and
George strands so thank you to all of
you one thing I think you all might like
to know is a day of data also holds some
follow-up events in the spring this year
enlighten line with a day of data theme
of reproducibility and we'll be having a
spring roof reproducibility workshop
that will be conducted by the Center for
open science and that will be held on
March third so we're really looking
forward to that there will also be a
series of other smaller lectures in the
spring and they've been outstanding in
the past as well so that information
will be sent out to everybody who
registered for today on to our
outstanding schedule of speakers our
first speaker this morning is Steve
gurbin deputy provost for research and
Eugene Higgins professor of physics
professor Gervin joined up Yale faculty
in 2001 as a professor of physics in
2007 was named deputy provost for
research his portfolio includes the
central campus science departments the
school of Forestry and environmental
studies and the school of an engineering
and applied science as well as various
institutes and initiatives additionally
he collaborates on science strategy with
the School of Medicine his academic
research is in the area of theoretical
quantum physics Stevie asleep I
professor gurbin holds a bachelor's
degree from bates college a master's
degree from the university of maine at
ms and PhD degrees from princeton and
recognition of his research and
contributions in the field professor
Griffin has been elected to the American
Association for the Advancement of
science the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences the royal swedish academy of
sciences and the US National Academy of
Sciences in two thousand
he was awarded the Oliver Buckley prize
of the american physical society without
further ado Steve Griffin
[Applause]
one hooked up to my one of my various
science dies today's astronomy so and
this only i'm just going to display on
that screen is that right so welcome and
welcome to this fabulous new space that
you'll be hearing more about as a home
of the yale center for research
computing
second one
okay so I don't have to talk to this
crowd about the in this modern era the
the flood of data the deluge of data the
tsunami of data which is coming into
Yale every day from all parts of the
world you genomics people are the worst
offenders you know who you are but
here's another source of data that flows
into Yale everyday anybody recognize
this this is the South Pole we're
standing 10,000 feet above sea level
there's 10,000 this is snow on the
surface but below there is 10,000 feet
of solid ice crystal clear light can
travel through it huge distances and
there are lots and lots of
photomultiplier detectors where they
melted a hole thousands of feet down
buried them in the ice and trillions and
trillions of neutrinos from the galaxy
are passing through every square
centimeter of that space every second
and occasionally one of them interacts
with the ice and gives off a bit of
light and the entire Antarctic ice shelf
is being used as a massive detector
which is then detecting these particles
from the Sun and from the galaxy and
from supernovas amazing and weird source
of data which flows into the University
each day and of course there are many
many bigger sources than that where
cryo-electron microscopy is about to
start on the west campus that'll be
[Music]
attempting to catch up with the genomics
people but the genomics people will
probably still win that race so many of
you the locals will have seen President
Saliva's communication to the University
ten days ago about the university
priorities and
academic investments that will be made
over the next 10 to 15 years at Yale and
while there's a bit of something in
there for everybody the far and away the
key top priority is going to be science
it's the it's the area that we need to
focus in to compete on the world stage
with the other really top universities
around the world and so of course our
ability to handle data and do great
science is going to be a key part of
that and we have to work on the
infrastructure needed to do that you see
here on a rendering of the new
multi-hundred million dollar science
building primarily devoted to biology
it's in place of the Gibbs building
which doesn't look as nice as this and
the that will be space for cryo-electron
microscopy optical microscopy all kinds
of biology labs physics and astronomy
labs all of which are going to be
producing more and more data so data of
course ties in with Yale fulfilling its
mission mission we we are an institution
that take our mission to do good in the
world very seriously we're trying to
improve the world through education
research practice clinical practice
educate leaders and free exchange of
ideas is absolutely a core principle and
there that is now including data so in
exchange for the opportunity to
um do research and fulfill yells mission
people have academic freedom to choose
the topics that they work on but have
some responsibilities to steward the
scholarly record to provide access to
the knowledge that they're generating
and of course responsible for making
sure that it's reproducible and for
allowing other people to check the
reproducibility of that data and that's
in this day and age super important
topic it gets complicated when you think
about the sort of traditional the
tradition of keeping your raw data I
hate to keep picking on the genomics
people but that's just becoming a
physical impossibility in some cases and
you have to decide what what what are
the standards of the field going to be
in terms of registering data and what
fraction of the what version of the non
raw data etc etcetera system complicated
questions as the ethos and different
subfields evolves there are a lot of
demands and expectations from many
sources the government is here to help
us and or was there's been a there's
been a requirement for about nine years
now that clinical trials should be in
the results summaries of the results
should be available to the public and
they should be registered before you
start in the result summarized when
you're done that enforcement has not
been strong but starting January 18th
it's going to be very strong and we have
to be prepared and have systems in place
to
with the institutional review boards
etcetera etcetera to make sure that that
happens everybody knows that OSTP has
been promulgating policies about open
access to data so have the journals and
there's various reproducibility
initiatives which are exposing potential
weaknesses in certain areas of certain
fields of research and I think it's very
important that we support those and if
we lose the trust of the public because
our results are not reproducible or
appear to have been influenced in some
way and appropriately it's just all over
for science so we absolutely have to
support those initiatives so we've been
thinking about this here and I've been
getting a lot of help from lemoore peer
who's sitting over here and who helped
organize this event Thank You labore
thinking about policies and guidelines
services and centers that that Yale has
now or should have now and education and
training not just for the young people
but also for faculty who are beginning
to see the tsunami data coming towards
them so lemoore has been chairing the
research data policy committee and we've
been trying to think about as part of
the kind of infrastructure for
supporting data and data science at Yale
and sharing of data and we need not just
physical infrastructure but policies in
place and we're going to be in the
coming months on a little road shows to
various departments and division
around the university talking about that
work that's been going on which includes
some sort of little white papers that
will talk about principles that we
should keep in mind as we develop
further policies as we build our
infrastructure and hardware and
consulting services with all those
things also new at the University is a
data governance committee which is
primarily focused on Yale's internal
administrative data classroom occupancy
registrar data financial data all kinds
of things like that you know to clarify
who has access to what how much is
public just all kinds of policy
questions that and attempt to define
very precisely where is the primary
record kept and please don't keep
inaccurate copies of that keep a link to
that primary one and we'll be able to
function more efficiently we help so
it's primarily about administration and
we have a number of services and centers
already in existence a research data
consultation group on this side of town
there's a stat lab and the CSSI that
Jill can tell you about in the
Institute's isps isps institution for
social and policy studies to the other
half of L'Amour's life they're pretty
serious about keeping records that have
been can still be accessed and
understood after you've written them
you'll hear more i think from Harlan
krumholz today it's been involved with
this
project in the med school and there's
four clinical trials and big data things
in the med school there's this data
coordinating Center so there are many
places around campus where education and
training and data science are exist or
coming into existence you have a
[Music]
two-and-a-half-year-old Yale Institute
for network science which is bringing
together people interested in network
social networks gene regulation networks
ethernet networks every possible thing
you can imagine the probably the most
heterogeneous group of people that are
willing to talk to each other on campus
and it's because they can all come and
learn if they don't know it already the
language of mathematics for describing
networks and of course big data is part
of that it will assuming it is approved
by the corporation in the coming week
there will be a data science initiative
announced involving in the FAS involving
the Department of Statistics computer
science other mathematics departments on
campus and was recently announced a Yale
center for biomedical data science and
one of my job's is to get these two
coordinated and talking to each other
the digital humanities lab is another
place where our humanists friends can
come and learn about numbers and other
inhuman objects stat lab this yale
center for research computing you'll
hear much more about in the next talk
from kieran and there are a lot of data
hackathons going on bo
from the organized from the top down and
a lot from like hack Yale from the
bottom up just students getting together
and having an event with thousands of
people from around the world showing up
to spend a weekend working on data so
this is intended to not be readable just
to illustrate the scale of things that
we either have or need to have in the
coming future in order to manage the
whole data life cycle and for those
parts of its research that are
externally funded their kind of the
pre-award award and post-award parts and
some of these things are in place many
more need to be worked on and so we have
a we have a big challenge ahead of us
and we'll be coming to talk to the yell
folks in this room about how we can make
the building appropriate services
infrastructure policies procedures to
deal with this flood of data which is
such an essential part of research today
thank you very much
[Applause]